[Music]
but it's touch and go for everyone on
this intensive care ward
in sofia's alexandrovska hospital about
30
of the patients won't survive covid
i'm very tired of watching people
going you know watching people going
worse
and cannot help them and trying to do my
best and doing my best and
after all they they're going
worse and worse and worse and worse
the third wave of covid has hit bulgaria
of those tested for the virus here
almost 20 percent are positive in
england by comparison
that figures now below 2 when we talk
with
with patients most of them said please
stay here
hold my hand for a while i'm alone i'm
so hello alone i cannot
see my heart if i cannot talk with them
but i have no
time to hold his hand his or her hand
because i have to watch other patients
and that is
very very very hard to live for
patients now are younger than last year
in their 40s and 50s
their conditions can deteriorate very
quickly if they have the british variant
of the virus
there is just one spare icu bed in this
hospital
and it will be occupied before the end
of the day i'm told
this covid19 crisis has got bulgaria's
health system
operating at its very limits
the hardest thing for the medical staff
here along with fatigue
is coping when patients die sometimes i
think did i
did everything for my patients but after
that when i
think for all things i did for my
patients i said okay i did everything
just
this is the disease and the diseases the
disease is
very very severe just over seven percent
of bulgarians have been vaccinated so
far
the lowest rate in the european union
that makes it more difficult
to see any light at the end of the
tunnel bernard smith al-jazeera
sophia